[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to at the game of thrones just
dropped one of its biggest and darkest
episodes ever the night king is no more
that doesn't mean it's all plain sailing
though and now the tides of war turn
toward Cersei who is amassing an army
that looks set to tear apart the
survivors of the Battle of Winterfell
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about episode 4 as well as what it could
lead to down the line this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
the latest release then I highly suggest
that you turn off now but without the
way thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my ending explain
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 8
episode 4 okay so just a quick recap of
episode 3 the 90-minute epic saw one of
the biggest lies ever put to television
Game of Thrones fired their lighting
director Jorah did one of the worst
white night plans ever an area did her
best impression of Rey in the last Jedi
in order to take the night king out
t1000 style episode 4 picks up with the
aftermath of the Battle of Winterfell
Westeros should win an award for
recycling after chopping up all those
stakes in using them as pyres but they
burn the bodies and the fires go far
beyond the funerals as John and Danny
realized that they never settled on who
would get the throne when this is all
over I don't know what it is about the
Starks and staring at each other but
this moment shows that there's
definitely going to be some tension
between them which is the main thrust of
the episode Danny decides to appoint
Gendry since the Lord which to me is
clearly a power player that will
probably gain his loyalty this all goes
to his head a bit and faster than you
can say I'm definitely not a virgin now
he proposes to area however area is now
able to put knight Kingkiller in a
tinder bio so she turns him down staying
any lady would be lucky to have you but
I'm
ladies I never have been that's not me
savage that's not the only part of the
episode that feels like it's from an MTV
dating show either with Jamie doing the
old baby it's called outside line and
Daenerys going to John hoping that he's
got the taste of auntie out of his mouth
Dany safe they can be together but only
if they keep their little secret which
if the roles were reversed right and it
was Danny's uncle telling her that it
would be yeah a bit creepy
naturally John doesn't seem to be into
it and this sets up the role that
Daenerys will probably travel down as
the Mad Queen it turns out she's not the
only one either in the war room the
parties discussed how they now only have
half an army whereas Uzis has doubled in
size this is pretty much the army that
your ex told you not to worry about it's
two times bigger it's got an amazing tan
and actually has a penis this doesn't
stop Danny though and the words we have
won the great war now we will win the
last one echo throughout the episode and
it's clear that she believes with her at
the helm there will be everlasting peace
which of course shows her arrogance and
conceited miss John pledges his armies
but you get the feeling that he's just
keeping her sweet until this is all over
and the Starks have the time to make a
power play bear in mind she doesn't have
much of an army left so there's not much
reason to bow to her when this is all
over to me this is confirmed by the fact
that Jon gathers his siblings for a
gossip and in true no you tell em style
John makes bran do it at this point
Jamie and Tyrion are chilling which is
when bran of Blackwater busts in and
tries his luck
sabbatarian offers to double the offer
which is great because we all know bran
loves money and killing people Torian
uses a smooth tongue later to try and
convince and said that Danny is the
dragon to back in this race but it seems
to fall on deaf ears with gossip
spreading faster than an episode of
loose women and them all realizing that
this new information is power
they know John has a better claim and
that more people like him so they tried
to come up with a way that the two can
share the throne but we all know deep
down that Dany isn't too good at that
meanwhile Daenerys sails forth with her
small fleet which is when we get our
first big debt in the episode with yuan
Greyjoy taking down Rey goal with Hugh
this crossbow we all know that was
John's ride so again this symbolizes
that Danny will be soul in her ownership
of power going forward Daenerys and a
fleet are wiped out with missandei going
missing amongst the chaos arriving back
at King's Landing we see Cersei doing a
best Bowser impression with the castle
becoming lined with citizens in order to
have a human shield word travels fast
with Varys finding out about this and
passing it on which Daenerys
wholeheartedly decides to ignore as she
wants a throne it's clear that the
citizens are starting to turn against
her though and many seem to be wanting
to see John as the rightful ruler
there's some amazing political campaign
ask statements such as make Westeros
great again yes we can and [ __ ] are
important which sounds like it was
ripped straight from Nigel Farage's new
Brack support he all in all though it
becomes clear that Dany or should I say
the mad Queen who won't share the throne
basically it looks like she's been
playing that new game of thrones mobile
app that pops up before every video and
it's decided she likes being Susie and
doesn't really want anyone to get away
speaking of Cersei we join her at King's
Landing to see she has Mercedes whatever
her name is I can never pronounce it
right so I'm just avoiding it with the
army waiting to see if Tyrion can get
through to her one last time he tries
his best even bringing up the death of
her baby but it doesn't really work and
the sundae goes out in its dark style
this sends Daenerys completely off the
rails and it becomes clear to me at
least that she has become the mad Queen
now completely blinded by her quest for
the throne and we'll take down Cersei
and all those at King's Landing and no
matter the cost the big stand out line
for me and the show is the last war line
which of course showcases her arrogance
over how good of a leader she will be
when she gains the throne she believes
she will be unchallenged which is of
course a stupid point of view to take
especially when people are already eager
to see Jon replace her I think this will
be her undoing and apparently the fifth
episode has a bigger battle than the one
from episode 3 which will probably see
the majority of their forces wiped out
and therefore she will be at the mercy
of the Starks who will wish to oust her
prompt
as soon as they can Danny likely won't
take this lying down though and I can
see the final episode dealing with the
bow between herself and John as they
both put their lives on the line in
order to secure leadership over the land
she's slowly starting to sound more and
more like her brother
and this arrogance often leads to a fall
which no doubt she is headed towards if
she remains the set on power obviously
and loved hear your thoughts on the
episode and if you like the direction of
this show is taking for its final few
episodes comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of every
episode so far which will be linked in a
playlist at the end of the video this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
you